the Joe Rogan experience it must for you
to have your life on the line over there
and see all this chaos and obvious
either lack of organization or outright
corruption
it must be insanely frustrating yeah I
mean the that'd be putting people in
cool they were clearly guilty of things
you know and then seeing them come out
or the legal system down there that I
got that I had to endure you know you
would have to go and do a face-to-face
with all these people all right go into
a federal courthouse leave your firearms
behind I could do a face-to-face with
these people inside that you just got
that you just got for however many tons
of cocaine or pot or whatever and then
go outside and they're outside you know
now now I know who you are
you know there's no anonymity in that in
that regard so but you would have to
sign things you know and then seeing
some of the people that were with you
working on your side and seeing then how
some of them would fall into corruption
charges and then sue the government and
then get your jobs back but now you have
somebody who's compromised within your
own unit Wow all right so they did try a
few things to try and clean out police
forces one of them was a plan they
called a this III plan it was like a
like a filter for police officers down
there it's still an it's still an action
but you know it's questionable if it's
effective or not I saw a lot of people
go through it and later on hunt they
would turn out to be cartel guys
basically they would do a background
check
FBI background check polygraph exam drug
testing all the all of these things to
see that you were you know clean to work
on these police forces the problem is
that the polygraphs turned out to be
unconstitutional to fire somebody over
them so a lot of these people got hired
back after they would fail poly basic
polygraph exam so again it's a lot of
attempts to clean it up you know and I
you would be on the on the level and all
these people won't be on the level but
they were still there so what what
percentage of people are not on the
level if you had a guess roughly
I mean I'd say would depend I'd say 30
percent probably that's a lot look I got
my experience of the people that I
worked at 30% went on you must cherish
the seventy of like family
yeah like family and you you would know
when some of these people weren't awful
level because you know I have this
running joke that I have this I I went
in with the same car that I drove out of
the office with yeah
shitty truck that I had that I bought
that I bought when I you know about my
own dime first truck first car and I
drove out of the office when I quit that
when I quit the job that same day you
know I drove it I drove out of the
office in that truck but a lot of these
you guys would come in with their you
know Hummers and H shoes and just weird
cars or like wait a minute does this
doesn't make sense like we are working
the same office why do you why do you
have a three-story house so obvious
though I prove it you know yeah but but
the obviousness of it oh yeah blatant
you're driving a nice car living in a
big house and everybody else is like
what yeah
there's you know there's this obviously
these this these unwritten rules of you
know you won't you wouldn't tell on this
guy of course but you know was obvious
yeah and when it came time to share
information of a certain kind or we're
gonna go over here and you would have to
turn around and look around see who was
listening you know you know you wouldn't
trust a lot of these people so how are
we gonna power gonna do our job if we
can't trust the people that were working
with us well who was it that recently
called for decriminalization they got
was it your president that called for a
decriminalization of all drugs in
America to go along with Mexico so what
it was yeah are i to do something about
the cartels yeah we're on the brink of
legalizing marijuana and in mexico right
now like there's been a few landmark
cases and you know it's gold rush type
situation right now there's a lot of
companies down there that that have had
experience up here that want to go down
there right so the culture is ready for
it i think do you think that would help
I don't know when it comes to legalizing
caught up here it hasn't helped down
there as far as lowering things it's
actually made things kind of worse how's
it made things worse they changed they
changed the they changed what they were
producing so that there was enough the
reason why there's a heroin heroin
epidemic up here and fentanyl epidemic
up here I think has some relationship
with how things that legalized up here
and how they switched um
product down there so lighter colored
heroin is coming down from Mexico and
I've seen that I work with law
enforcement up here in the u.s. doing
classes and kind of you know they send
me things like what do you think about
that said and I've seen that lighter
colored heroin pop up in places as far
office your car that's you so you know
because of the color yeah the color are
the smell the consistency you can kind
of tell if it's Asian or how it works
it's a different strain like it's it's a
probably a different strain and it's
also the amount of Sun it gets in the
region where it's been being grown whose
height higher altitude so it's lighter
color not a stinky I don't know but I
think it's a relationship that that kind
of relates to the legalization issue
down there they didn't affect them in
the pockets they just switched product
it's got to be it's such a strange
relationship because the reason why
these drug cartels have so much power is
because they're selling drugs to the
United States yeah so it's like you have
this connection to this country that has
this great big wall that it wants to
build and on one side everybody's buying
up all the illegal drugs and the other
side everyone's killing everybody to try
to make and sell these illegal drugs
yeah I mean and there's a lot of holes
underneath that wall and drones your own
technology is that wall gonna help
anything
well the wall has already been up for a
few years part of it and in place like
Tijuana which is like one of the richest
drug routes on the planet and it's the
drugs are caught the same you know it's
the same it's yeah and what about like
the ocean can't we just take a boat I've
I've seen one large submarine in my time
working really a large like like
military size like like scientific size
well
[ __ ] to somebody buy a submarine online
apparently really yeah you could buy a
submarine you can buy a small submarine
for a small amount of money I think the
main part of the submarine ownership is
maintained maintenance that was the
reason we found it is that it wasn't
properly maintained so it sunk yeah it
it actually don't what actually floated
couldn't sink oh and it had a bunch of
things hanging off behind it but
summaries scare the [ __ ] out of me you
can't see where you going well so there
so yeah I've seen submarines drones like
a squadron of drones with a bunch of
loads on it
yeah Wow how heavy can a drone get still
fly lap times I've seen fool like two
kilos on it really yeah
so just fly-in the coke over the top
yeah the only reason we I found out
about those one of those crashed in a
roadside next to the border fence were
you around when that CIA drug plane
crashed in Mexico with tons of cocaine
on it yeah I wasn't there but I bet was
aware of that situation what the [ __ ] is
that about
I mean realistically there's there's a
lot of Americans running around in
Mexico yeah that's that's that that's in
and there's a lot of cowboys right yeah
a lot of people say listen we just make
this one run like the government doesn't
give a [ __ ] about us my passion sucks it
could be you know could be you know
every now and then you know and this is
this is this isn't a secret every now
and then you would see a dude out there
that's blond tall and has a bunch of
tattoos that don't belong down there
working on the military side of things
in Mexico or some dudes doing something
in someplace near land then you will get
a call you know oh they're they're fine
just you know just leave them alone
yeah so who knows you know who knows so
if it's 3 out of 10 we're corrupt where
you were it might be like 110 CIA guys I
mean
you know usually we would get to since I
have a pretty good just spoken English I
would get I will get sent places for
training or for liaison work with some
people that would go down there and I
would never know what the hell some of
these people were from you know hmm
so who knows
[Applause]